I'm single Selena Gomez unapologetically
shooting her shot
yep so put it all out on the table in a
new video posted to tick tock calling
out to a player during a soccer game
making it clear that she's on the market
[Music]
but I love you so much
I think my advice is to not be afraid
fans pointed out that Selena was serving
total Alex Russo Vibes well you might be
president of the school but I'm
president of getting things I want oh my
goodness it might have been all fun and
games but it looks like she's still on
the hunt from Mr Right I hate it when
girls are like oh my gosh my crush
doesn't even know that I exist like girl
my crush doesn't even exist yeah Selena
posted this takes out clip back in March
can't keep my hands to myself in a
poking fun at her love life is nothing
new I think it's empowering when you're
able to do things on your own but when
it comes to her love life Selena was
most recently spotted out in New York
City with Zayn Malik in March
before that she was linked to the chain
smokers Drew Taggart
[Music]
But ultimately cell set the record
straight on her Instagram story when she
clarified I'm single well I think it's
nice to have a little bit something to
myself before Drew Selena dated the
weekend and of course Justin Bieber on
and off for several years what do you
mean until they split and Justin went on
to marry Haley Bieber I think it was the
right decision for me it seems like
she's still looking for that special
someone but for so self-love takes
priority it's important just to remain
positive I'm at that age where I feel
like that's what matters is making sure
I'm healthy and people are happy that I
love
[Music]